now to the discovery of those additional
documents Mark classified this time in
President Biden's Delaware home it is
more trouble for the president in a case
that could get worse in the days ahead
attorney general Merrick Garland says a
special counsel will investigate the
handling of those documents from the
Obama Administration Adriana Diaz broke
this original story it has become the
story of this short year and she joins
us now Adriana good morning good morning
the appointment of the special counsel
comes as CBS News has learned that
multiple former aides to President Biden
from his time as vice president have
been interviewed we're also learning
more about the timeline
the extraordinary circumstances here
require the appointment of a special
counsel attorney general Merrick Garland
has tapped Robert herb a veteran
prosecutor who served under former
president Donald Trump to investigate
the possible unauthorized removal and
retention of classified documents
discovered at locations connected to
President Biden the stunning
announcement came just hours after the
White House acknowledged that a small
number of classified documents had been
found in the garage of President Biden's
Wilmington residence and in a room next
door so the material was in a locked
garage yes as well as my Corvette but as
I said earlier this week people know I
take classified documents and classified
materials seriously the latest
Revelation follows the White House's
admission earlier this week after
questioning by CBS news that Mr Biden's
lawyers had found roughly 10 classified
documents on November 2nd in this
building about a mile from the White
House where Mr Biden once had an office
that office was not off authorized for
storage of classified documents less
than two weeks later the justice
department started its preliminary
review December 20th is when President
Biden's lawyers found the additional
classified materials at his Wilmington
home his lawyers also searched his
Delaware vacation house and said no
classified records were found there it's
just a question of getting information
and getting ready to make some very
significant decisions about a sitting
president Alberto Gonzalez served as
White House counsel and then attorney
general in the George W Bush
Administration he says the appointment
of a special counsel is critical it was
simply the right thing to do
irrespective of criticism
not just the Republicans but the
American public they need to have
confidence
that the investigation is going to be
independent and fair and thorough how do
we find out a second location and he's
shocked by it on Capitol Hill House
speaker Kevin McCarthy questioned
President Biden's transparency he
knowingly knew this happened going into
election going into interviews this is
what makes America not trust their
government
the White House says proper protocols
were followed now it's worth noting that
in just the last two months attorney
general Garland has appointed now two
special counsels to investigate the
handling of sensitive materials by both
the sitting president and the former
president Donald Trump who withheld
documents despite repeated requests Gail
Adriana thank you very much